now let's bring in Jamie yuccas who's at
Charleston's historic seaside landmark
the battery Jamie what kind of
conditions are you seeing so far this
morning Toni I can tell you that the
conditions have continued to worsen
throughout the morning we've seen three
to five inches of rain but could get a
foot or more here in Charleston take a
look you can see over the seawall that
the water just keeps splashing up the
water just so high and and the winds
being so violent right now gusts have up
to 75 miles per hour and this is what
people are really concerned about as
this water comes in here you can see
that it's going into the low-lying areas
and it eventually it will creep up to
the roadways we've had many road
closures in the area we were driving all
night long there's about 70 different
Road road closures throughout Charleston
County it's because of those flash
floods what happens is you'll get a very
strong amount of rain that will come in
it'll flash flood some of the roadways
here in low-lying areas and then at some
point it will recede a little bit but
you have emergency workers that are very
concerned about people driving around
because as we saw power lines down there
are also a hundred and sixty thousand
people without power in the area this
morning that number is expected to
increase as we start to see these winds
whip up I want to show you the wind
gusts you can kind of tell right here as
the water starts coming in at this point
in time just how strong the winds have
been and it's going to just continue to
do that throughout the morning we'll
keep checking in Tony a dangerous surge
there in these low-lying areas Jamie
thank you very much